many questions remain unanswered over
reports that hunter biden lied on a gun
application
in 2018 when he answered no
on if he was an unlawful drug user or
addict
which would have been a felony offense
hunter biden and his family have been
open
about his struggles with drug abuse he
was actually kicked out of the navy
reserve years prior for testing positive
for cocaine two republican senators
wrote a letter to the fbi the secret
service and the atf
to find out exactly what happened and if
secret service agents
intervened in this case one of those
senators is ron johnson of wisconsin and
he joins me now
senator johnson such a pleasure to have
you on the show today
well rachel hope you're doing well i am
so listen let's get right to it the fbi
was inside of that gun shop
were they there to investigate or were
they there to cover up a crime
well rachel the sad saga of hunter biden
continues and
this is this is of many strange stories
this is one of the stranger ones
but no the the service really has no
role in this whatsoever which is why the
the gun shop owner did not turn over the
the background check records to the
secret service because that's the
purview
jurisdiction the atf
so again this is just a very strange
story but
as you talked about in your opening
segment the
double standard you know the unequal
treatment of of individuals
hunter biden has gotten a pass time and
time again from law enforcement
from what i can determine and this is
just another example of that
yeah it's such a great point i mean how
many young men have had this happen to
them they've
lied on a application and they're in
jail now
but hunter biden is not do are federal
authorities cooperating i mean i know
you've sent the letter
no not really we we have a number of
outstanding requests from secret service
regarding his protectee status when he
was uh
when his father was still vice president
he ended that protected
status of the secret service the day a
time magazine
came article came out revealing his
connection with barissima so he
supposedly ended the
protected protection from the secret
service but yet a year later the secret
service was somehow involved with them
so
we've never got to the bottom of that
and we'll see that we get to the bottom
of this
i have to i i know i want to move on
from hunter but i can't because i just
have to ask you one more thing because
i'm one of those americans that is still
steamed
that the american voters didn't have the
full story about his laptop and the
corruption caught on that
um back in 2020 before the election do
you think we're ever going to get to the
bottom of that do you think we'll find
out who the big guy is
well i have my doubts you know one of
the reasons i really want to make sure
that
president trump had a second term we
were finally getting our arms around
some of this we were getting
we were able to extract some information
from the agencies that were
pretty well slow walking all of our
requests but but i just have my doubts i
mean
obviously our report was completely
ignored by the media that's in the back
pocket of the democrats and
the liberal left uh and this
with the new administration i'm just
afraid this is all going to be buried
and goes down
the black hole of history right it's sad
um you were just down at the border
which is another sad thing that you just
saw
tell us what you are what you and the
senators were able to see
and gather i know you've been on this
story for long before this crisis you've
been following the border and and
the action down there well the misguided
policies of this administration is going
to lead to greater in
inhumanity it's one of the great uh
unreported stories here is is just the
the the human trafficking component of
this
and just the the depredations one of the
things we learned from
border patrol for example was that uh
one of the techniques of these human
traffickers some of the most evil people
on the planet that's that's what these
policies are are facilting
some of the most evil people on the
planet their multi-billion dollar
uh business plan but one of the things
they do is when they're
interdicted by a cbp boat they'll throw
a child overboard
into the currents of the of the rio
grande that's how some of these children
drowned uh they sell children that came
out in testimony before our committee in
they sold a child for 84 dollars so that
people could exploit our very lenient
asylum laws when it comes to family
and by an administration knows all these
things and yet they completely
dismantled
what worked you know president trump
pretty well stopped the flow
of unaccompanied children and family
units
and in doing so stopped the the
human trafficking business model and the
depredations
and president biden dismantled all that
and now we're seeing it
to a greater extent than it ever has
been this is a tragedy this is a
disaster
and it's so unfortunate we were so close
to finally controlling our border
stopping this flow so we could turn our
attention
to solving the issue with daca children
and
and setting up a legal immigration
system that works right
it's such a sad situation and so
unnecessary um
and thank you for going down there i
don't know how many other democrat
senators were there but
i saw there was a lot of republicans
let's hope we get some more democrats
looking at the situation
maybe their hearts will be turned um by
this and maybe they'll be able to
convince
the administration to change these
terrible policies senator johnson you
are one of the bravest senators there
are and and that's why the media
and um the democrats hate you but i
think you ought to wear it as a badge of
honor thanks so much for joining us on
this show today
have a great night stay healthy all
right